schon wieder hat sich im hintergrund
positioniert na ja mach dich vielleicht
zu sicher dass dieses kalenders ist
nicht willkommen zu einem nein hieß es
heute haben wir einen adventskalender
wert wir schon hier noch angehängt
richtig ich nehme den einmal heute
testen wir dem und fabulösen
eventkalender von maxi naschkatze habe
ich dir gesagt das heißt aber eigentlich
das labor arzt gefunden und ich dachte
ich habe ihr keine geschmacksnerven und
mein bruder ist der beste da schon da
wirst du nicht siehst kannst
ich bin wirklich wann hast du für den
geschmack sagt jetzt zeigst du eben fast
gleich gross jetzt ist so viel größer
als ich crystal verschlanken
[Musik]
falls sie sich wundern guido ist 195
kurs also
ich würde sagen lasst uns den test
beginnen wir machen auf das türchen okay
dass man in die hand biss und glas 55
handverlesen aus liebe zur qualität der
gipfel sind sind stern und dann können
wir es probieren
ich finde man schmeckt immer am anfang
kurz sind aber sonst gar nicht so fremd
und dann waren wir müssen punkte
vergeben
null punkte ist schlecht 5 punkte ist
hammermäßig geil
denn die auto zwischen zwei und drei
kirchen normal und kein glas was
wirklich nur gummibärchen
aber man kann es auch nicht zu vergessen
mit thomas münzel zu auf deutsch also
überraschung das ist wieder ein
[Musik]
schön aus naja also die erste zeit zum
garten sind zucker zucker und dann kommt
abgesagt aber irgendwie bin ich nicht so
ein fan davon machen wir weiter mit dass
du fragst ja das sind hart caramelle
assist zum lutschen wird dann vielleicht
überspringen wird
auch zu dann können wir die verlosen
[Musik]
wieder gut machen würden tagung nach
seiner hand haben sondern halten aber
nicht essen das ist süßer bratapfel
bonbons größtes ist schon was ganz
spannend was du brauchst du hast gerade
verdammt recht keine april also
aber sind zb hast du das gefühl dass uns
dem tor also ein bratapfel bestattungen
auf will was ich komme schon es besteht
sind aber sind es gar nicht drin in den
zutaten und ich bin das hat auch nach
zimt geschmeckt
ich bin mal waren wir überfordert
ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht das sag
ich ja hier an dieser stelle aber das
problem ist dass liest du ja nicht aber
die verpackung es wirklich schön wieder
heim kalender hat gekostet
euro die pompons und so wenig machen
also jetzt sind wir bei kirchen nummer
fünf
ich glaube der prinz kalenders das
nächste ist gemütlicher kamin zeit und
ich muss leider sagen das müssen wir gar
nicht probieren denn es ist das gleiche
wie und anderen motto also das mit dem
mistelzweig ist ein gefragtes gleich das
haben wir gar nicht aufmachen münchen
nummer 67 nikolaus am 6
zimmer oder in die wände lassen ein
großes glas oder sieht sogar drauf happy
nikolaus also kannst du mal die hand
nehmen das ist so groß und das ist
gefüllt mit gummibärchen
ich glaube das wird ein bisschen
aufregender schmecken da drin sind so
kleine nikoläuse so gummi nikoläuse hier
ist der 1
süßen fällt mir ein schulden schlechter
[Musik]
april weiter das auf weitere
johannisbeere brombeere erdbeere unser
hindere die man von jedem mehreren macht
also ich finde bis jetzt ist das glaube
ich der beste bestätigt wo auch weil die
ja ein bisschen geschmack hat so sauer
[Musik]
stell dir mal vor wir essen ja immer nur
ein bonbon aber da sind wir voll viele
drin schon mal vor du isst jeden tag
diese menge an bonbons
in die breite wachsen
[Musik]
7 das gefällt mir schneeflöckchen heißt
es hier muss so ein bisschen nach
karamell und künstlich auch höhere
anteil und mama schnecken marshmallow
[Musik]
dadurch dass es jetzt nicht gesehen hast
ich finde zum beispiel die farbe blau
und weiß würde jetzt für mich wie
karamell schmecken
deswegen habe ich irgendwie gleich alles
anderes gedacht aber dadurch dass du nur
den geschmack
ja okay jetzt kommt das gummi beck
[Musik]
vorher die weihnachtsfeier rein ja ja
wusste entschuldigung der dichterin sich
aber sowohl ein und wurde nur ein
steinchen jetzt nicht den kopf über ein
das ist also etwas zu sie habe absolut
keine bewertung gemacht von 953 jetzt
kommen wir auf regen ja das ist
[Musik]
schneller stabiler welche die hantel
warum haben sie dann ein bratapfel nicht
rein gemacht das ist ein richtiger
betrug den ich auf decke wieder sind
hart und bonbon aber das würde ich jetzt
nicht probieren
das heißt er wird sich etwas schmecken
jingle bells nicht hingeben
wir gucken was das nächste ziel früher
leider nicht immer so verpackt sind
die brauchen wir probieren weil die sind
sogar lassen bis hin zu probieren
die heißen die hanse nordpol und da sind
die eisbären trafen stefan packung ja
ich glaube die worten schmecken wie
diese
da sie noch cool wäre irgendwie nordpol
ließ der trainer offen
du kannst du das wetter respektiere das
ist wieder so ein hartes bombe nicht
besitzen
aber das nur zucker sirup und zitronen
also dass nur zitronensäure der
geschmack dann nach der 23
[Musik]
dieses mal knapp
also es hat wieder was gemacht ihr 13
sternenhimmel darauf habe ich keinen
bock noch mal wieder die gleiche sache
wie bei den nikolaus
also einfach so wären gummis was kommt
nach der 14
[Musik]
der biss fest
der geschmack ist zu wenig da dass man
sagt ja das ist ein ich finde das
schmeckt schon wieder nach karamell also
nach berg kürzeln kommt die wir gucken
jetzt machen jetzt schnelldurchlauf
als nächstes haben wir christbaumkugeln
also schon wieder die gleichen scheiß 1
aber solange wir nicht gegessen
wer zuerst kommt 20 minuten später zwei
stunden später sechs stunden so viel
später dass es dem alten erzähler zu
blöd wurde an einen neuen anstellen
musste nicht schade gongondy bogen
bonbons die sind mit feuerroten haaren
sahne kokosfett sojamilch und
lebkuchengewürz für die kernenergie
gewürz in die fresse du hast es in der
einfachheit gegessen richtig lecker das
ganz genau die kuchen schmeckt lecker
und nachher sogar 8
nebenbei schlacht 1 haben wir wie bei
dem rudolf und das ist wieder so eine
nase wie bei rudolf also zucker außen
rum und weil ich ihnen so nach der
18 kommt meint simon glauben das wird
sie auch schnecken balkon waffe brösel
ok dass wir probieren ja ein bisschen
aus wien ist komisch so waffe geschmack
sondern bonbon ist auf jeden fall mit
lebkuchen bei corner nummer 20
das ist wieder mal schneller über den
schneemann wir probieren das hat mir
jetzt schon einmal nach der 20 kombi in
der 21 ist drin
make a wish so wären also gummibären
aber die müssen wir auch nicht probieren
nach der 21 kommt ein glas
feuerzangenbowle helfer 50
die lasse ich aber mal zum verlosen dann
haben wir so ein glashaus wir verlosen
können okay und ich habe also das könnt
ihr mal in die kommentare schreiben
für mich sehen wir uns nach 23 conti 23
vorletzte typischen rettung eine portion
vorfreude sind wieder so rote herzen die
hatten wir schon also müssen wir die
wieder nicht probieren
ich glaube auch wir sind jetzt richtig
auch vorfreude auf das 24 türchen und
das machen wir jetzt auch oder
versuchten das war auch zu wollen
du musst deinen finger richtig rein und
so auch so nach oben heben
wurde ja auch gummi sind
weihnachtsmännern und es sieht doch so
schön
hallo weihnachtsmann hier bitteschön
können sie was man essen in
verschiedenen schneemann
naja banken dieses video sozusagen
wollen dort zu drehen
danke schön dass durch ihr was hast du
mein assistent hat gesagt die haupt und
die hauptrolle war ich muss sie erklären
wie man die erklärt auf polnisch youtube
videos auch videos gefunden hatte und
wir sehen uns im oktober wieder schreibt
gerne was für trends kennen dann wieder
noch testen sollen vielleicht nicht nur
zucker besteht sogar nimmer sehen
[Musik]
da hat er noch den blick rausgehauen
die leute drehen
[Musik]